brian yarbrough taking the hill the 29
year old left-hander making his 16th
appearance 11th start putting together a
pretty good season so far you see in
just over 80 innings david to the right
side base hit that's a 12-game hitting
streak 20 hits in his last 12 games is
on in front of show head oh and a swing
and a miss he had him out in front right
there
nicely done by yarborough to get the
first out
and dispose of ohtani
double play ball there
bronco
won it over to first for two dejoy
six four three taylor made patrick
sandoval taking the hill for the angels
going out there for his tenth appearance
seventh start two and two record good
numbers so far 39 innings 40 punch out
so that just the 15 walks does have
seven home runs allowed
that is strike three for the 14th time
he has put a three-pitch strikeout in
the book
[Music]
i think he lost it it's over his head
he's in trouble
a rose arena as ward hustle on around
into second there's a couple of bases
lost it at one point then had it bound
over his head i think that falls and out
so minute first and third now
here's the top of the order fletcher
he pops it into short right margaux on
the run lao out there and who's going to
catch it loud and now he turns makes a
wide throw and it's going to go to the
dugout screen and now the throw they're
going to get him at the plate
how about all of that that throw was
wide went to the screening below the
railing in front of the angels dugout
and as ward broke to the plate the rays
retire him with zanino putting the tag
on it
well
not your conventional
double play
it's 4-1-2 and ward is out on the
backside of two
on the move trying to swipe it back in
there ohtani with the stolen base 11
stolen bases on the year yeah the home
run derby participants leading the team
in stolen bases
[Music]
bill gosling grounded out to short back
in the second inning gosling breaks his
back tries to shoot the hole hurrying up
the line that's an rbi
it hit the base on her gosselin and he
will move into second as that one kicked
away
so the angels strike it's one to nothing
the goose is loose
brandon lau
that's a high shot back into deep right
that will get out of here home run for
brandon loud
he connects on the old one pitch
and the rays are on the board to tie
this game at one
[Applause]
denino
lands it into length center field that's
going to
drop in there lagaris made a stop with
the bare hand otherwise that ball almost
bounced by him
and by sticking up the bare hand he
holds
zanino
going to try to beat it out and the
throw gets away from waltz that's going
to roll to the dugout
they're trying to get kier meyer to go
down to second but he had busted it by
the bag at first not realizing what had
happened
zunino winds up in third kirmeyer at
first
[Music]
swings right through it a fastball
screams into his glove with frustration
six strikeouts through five
it's up he hit it hard
firm ground ball to set the table for
showhead
drives it right field over the head of
the right fielder margot
up off the base of the wall ohtani
flying around they're going gonna send
fletch toward the plate the relay the
slide shohei with a double and an rbi
and the angels lead it two to one
and a wider into left that's gonna drop
for a base hit there you go
wander franco on a 2-1 pitch leads off
the bottom of the sixth
with a single
to pitch and a liner into center field
we'll see franco do some running
he's headed to third and will stop there
on the base hit
off the battle meadow solander franco
goes to third
and the rage on that base hit by meadows
have been on the corners with nobody out
joy has a couple strikeouts on the day
there's a shot
defender right that baby's out of here
home run
g-man joy
and the rays take the lead
a three-run blast
and now it's four to two
ward high fly ball toward the alley in
left center field
off the base of the wall taylor easy in
the second he's got a pair of doubles
and the angels punch right back
to left field
they played in the other way off the
glove a diving intent grump comes off
baseball comes free lagarus into second
with a double the tying run is at second
base it's a double and an rbi it's four
to three a rosary now let's hope he's
all right out there or it's second
that's lagarres
shohei
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gets it done
here's the goose he's got a couple of
hits
gosselin drives that one down the line
into the corner that baseball goes
towards the pole
that one got up and got out of here oh
fly high goose
that's a hover the angels lead it
the goose loose against a right-handed
pitcher goes yard three hits in the game
for the goose
balls in one strike
here's the next pitch and
shohei ohtani lifts a high fly ball
that's hit pretty well out into left
center field and it's out of here
shohei is having a day for the angels
he hits a home run here and his last
three at bats he's had a double triple
now homer that's an add-on run the
angels lead it 6-4 and sunday is show
do it the time return to their winning
ways with a six to four victory over the
raise today shohei ohtani certainly the
big hero in this one but it started
early with patrick sandoval on the mound
again six 6-4 the angels win